okay all right i'll explain
maybe it's because i did um i mean i did
psychology at uni but i thought it was
like a
i guess i'm just i like reading um
pavlov's dog
uh pavlov was a psychologist um
and yeah that's always what i thought
when i heard pavlov but anyway
um pavlov was interested in behavioral
psychology so did i give you guys any
copies at all
one two three four five so particularly
the idea that you could govern
something's behavior
by um governing the external stimuli to
the system
so thinking about um humans and
just like living creatures uh do you
need to eat
yeah okay good wait four six
oh i see okay oh i get it right sorry so
anyway
uh pavlov did this experiment right and
he said uh
wait hold on four for you guys and two
more for you guys
he said all right um i have a bunch of
dogs
and i know that when it's dinner time
right um i always ring a bell
okay so he rings a bell and then he
sends out food
right and then the food they can smell
and so they come over and then so maybe
you have over okay
so every day i don't know how long he
did the experiment for but obviously he
did it for a while because he sort of
was conditioning them to expect
the rhythm of belle with dinner right so
that
stimuli got connected in their brains
and the neural pathways and
i didn't do brain bees so you'll have to
spay the details but
eventually what he found was after such
a long time actually doing the
experiment that if he rang the bell
but didn't offer any food the dogs would
still start salivating
as if they were food right so they were
conditioned so much to think
bell food and digestion and all that
kind of thing right
that you know salivation is a it's an
unconscious process your brain is doing
it
without you saying salivate brain so
that i can get ready for digesting food
so your brain just kind of takes care of
that
but it's not inside of the thing okay
well these these two things are so
connected
as soon as i hear the bell i might as
well start salivating because i'm going
to get food right
so pavlov's dog is all about you can
train someone
um to do something instinctively
give it a sense so for instance when i
first started driving my instructor
taught me when you see red lights in
front of you
whether it's like you know a traffic
light or someone's brake lights you
should instinctively brake
which is a good instinct to have right
because it means that you're driving
along
and maybe you're not particularly you're
looking at other situation where you're
looking at mirrors or something like
that
and your brain sees someone breaking in
front of you so you break straight away
without actually thinking of whether
that's a good idea or not
which is generally quite a good idea
because our reflexes
the time to think breaking slowing down
maybe i should slow down as well okay
i'll slow down that takes like you know
half a second which is a long time when
you're traveling at 80 k's an hour
right so anyway that's one